The revival of NBC's "Night Court" became an
instant hit in early 2023, thanks in large part
to the return of a fan-favorite character. But
this is not the same Dan Fielding. Here's why.
Much of the revival's appeal comes from a
carefully considered balance of nostalgia
and likable new elements. Credit for that
goes directly to series star Melissa Rauch,
who got the revival going as part of
her deal with Warner Bros. Television.
There was one link to the previous
series that couldn't be overlooked:
John Larroquette. His performance as assistant
district attorney Dan Fielding garnered four
consecutive Emmy awards for supporting actor
in a comedy series. Bringing Fielding back
meant dealing with a familiar character's
past, present, and future all at once.
Dan Fielding has been described as many things,
but in a nutshell he's a lothario who cares
only about his own desires. "Night Court"
viewers in the '80s and '90s were often treated
to Fielding's exploits with a host of women.
While some were humorous, others hinted
at a sense of sadness and longing the
assistant district attorney hid
all too well. Reintroducing the
character after thirty years offered
an opportunity to delve deeper into
who he has become and avoid treading
water with regurgitated plot points.
The "Night Court" revival addressed where
Fielding landed in its first episode. Judge
Abby Stone sought out the character after losing
a key component to her court. Instead of offering
him his old job, the new judge asks him
to assume the role of public defender.
The first exchange between Stone, daughter of
former judge Harry Stone, and Fielding quickly
sets the tone for where he stands today. Gone is
the ladies' man who was constantly pursuing new
partners, and what remains is a man changed
by life's biggest moments — love and loss.
"That is what sold Sarah on the place."
"Is Sarah your wife?"
"She was."
The former assistant district attorney
revealed that he had indeed been married,
finding love with his deceased wife. Her loss
left Fielding searching for some solace but
only finding work as a process server.
The job kept him near the legal community
without practicing law — something he
grew tired of while viewers were away.
Much like in the original series, there's
more than meets the eye with Fielding. With
Fielding's return also came a new,
more modern attitude towards women.
No longer was he the man who couldn't
encounter a female character without
making salacious comments. He's still
sardonic, but he’s clearly much wiser.
Early episodes touch on Dan Fielding's current
thoughts on dating and love as a widower,
with Episode 4, "Dan vs. Dating," offering
the clearest picture of where he is now. In
the episode, a woman asks him for his
phone number, but he initially avoids
getting in touch with her, choosing instead
to dine alone. Abby's clerk, Neil, however,
pushes "Send" on Dan's drafted text, and
the woman later meets him at the restaurant.
The latter part of the episode is where
the audience experiences a deep dive into
someone they thought they knew. It turns
out that the woman just wanted a "fling,"
which was actually a cover for an identity theft
revenge plot related to an old case, so Fielding
unwittingly discovers how much his wife's
memory lingers. Before the ruse is revealed,
what would have previously been a one-night stand
becomes a strong source of character development.
"She changed me. I mean, the old me
would have been very much into this,
but I'm a different man now."
TV Fanatic's Diana Keng encapsulated what
many viewers were feeling after
the episode's debut, writing,
"There is sweeping romanticism in
the thought of Dan Fielding giving
up his rapscallion ways for the love of a good
woman. Or maybe the love of the right woman."
None of this would be possible without the
talents of John Larroquette. Long against
returning to the role, the process
of meeting Rauch and seeing what
the creative team had in mind convinced
him to give it a try. Producing as well
as starring in the series gave him the
ability to shape his character's current
incarnation — something expertly acted in
this episode as well as the entire revival.
According to the actor, don't expect Fielding
to be back to his old ways. He told Deadline,
"The man is 75 years old, nobody wants to see
that and I certainly don't want to play that.
So whatever we'll do in the future about that will
always be glancing blows to that sort of homage."